and now to present the award for the
best achievement in art direction is the
girl who made me wish I had been 16 in
the summer of 42 miss Jennifer O'Neil
and a young man who did his own growing
up in another summer the last picture
show mr. Timothy bottoms
when I heard that Dalt Oaks Charlie
Chaplin was going to be on the show
tonight I ran out and saw as many of his
pictures as I could and I just loved
them I loved them all
even the rinky-dinky sets but I have a
secret ambition it's to do one of those
classy lush MGM movies with marble
corridors a mile long and hundreds of
crystal chandeliers wearing a dress that
vividly worn gone with the wind someday
you will the award we are giving is for
best achievement in art direction and
the nominees are the adramal distrain
art direction
boris levin and william tunki set
direction reveal of it Bedknobs and
Broomsticks art direction john b
Mansbridge and peter ellen shaw set
decorations and me'll Curie and hal
gozman Fiddler on the Roof art direction
Robert Boyle and Michael stringer set
direction
Peter LaMotte Mary Queen of Scots art
direction Terrence Marsh and Robert
Cartwright set decoration Peter Cohen
Nicholas and Alexandra art direction
John box
Ernest Archer Jack max Ted and Hill
Ferrando set direction Vernon Dixon and
the winner is in this the winner is
Nicholas and Alexandra
accepting the award on behalf of John
bucks earnest dr. Jack max dead and
he'll Ferrando Vernon Dixon mr. Franklin
Shatner those five gentlemen are sold
enormous ly talented it's a shame if
they cannot be here to pick up this
award for my colleagues for my friends
this is terrific thank you